hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to dungeon nightmares
2. now you guys seem very eager for me
to get back in back into this I don't
know if because there haven't been that
many scary scary games uh recently and
you guys really want me to get back into
the scares
someone leave their clothes good good
question now when I continue this game I
don't know if it deposited me on the
first or the second
where to go where am I where did I spook
myself into yeah bloody goblets and
everything okay now I don't know if it
deposited me
on the second night or the first night
god with this game just calm down let me
get my intro done so either way you guys
are very eager for me to get back into
this and I want you guys to know
that I fully intend
to see this through until I'm too much
of a baby to continue because that's
what I do with my life
anyone behind door number one
anyone behind door number two wait what
the hell no one could hear you scream
down here I bet hundreds of thousands of
people can hear me scream from down here
unless all my neighbors hate me and they
can hear me scream too just an ordinary
just an ordinary for us
what the [__] was that
it wasn't an ordinary Voz
okay that's a bad noise
what is it
okay
all right
cool
okay my heart needs to stop beating for
a second but not completely can you game
please give me chance to breathe
thanks
Godzilla
still something around I'm trying to
play a game
there's nothing inside I want
what about the auto fact what about the
artifact
Mr skeleton man I don't know if he's
gonna be pursuing me in this particular
endeavor
but
I'm a man I'm a manly man I'm a big
strong manly man
I ain't Afra oh God in my light
I ain't afraid of no Skellington
I ain't gonna let anybody stop me from
getting to the prize
good God
all right come on
I'm sweating already
oh man my legs are all clammy and gross
no one would ought to come near me right
now so scared I've read this note up a
jillion times it's not true I'm not
scared
what do we got what do we got
huh More Steam
you wouldn't steam me again you know
that I'm immune to those types of scares
okay how do I get away from that
what was it
foreign
calm down game
I don't like you
still chasing me
still chasing me give me give me give me
give me give me give me give me what's
in here oh I'm lost and I can't do it
out that's very helpful for me John John
you're not being very egregious to
getting me out of here alive
God damn that lady what a giant piece of
[__]
what on a bag of ass what a silly silly
Sally
okay I'm gonna do this once just because
I don't want to repeat myself
did my make my point clear he awakes
looked like a lady over there but I
don't know if he's awake why should I be
so worried
that is not very helpful just the
sparking
useless little bits of metal good great
how the hell am I gonna get out of here
alive whoa oh God
son of a [__] it just hit me hard and
fast and I didn't have any chance to
react
okay all right I'll try another door I
guess
shut up shut up shut up don't whisper in
me I hate whispering
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut it up it to die I just
picked up a note and you tell me to die
again isn't that a little rude isn't
that exactly what I said last time
good
come on with this baloney oh hi hey bony
how you doing bonester the bone Meister
the bit oh
okay that's a guillotine I don't want to
go that way that's Bad News Bears for me
so okay if I go down that way there's
another path that I didn't go down
originally this was a door that was
blocked up let's see oh oh it's a little
more agreeable this time
of a [__]
all right what do we got give me give me
give me give me something good
give me some good you found me who's he
P more really P more P more pee my pants
I'm not wearing any really I'm not trust
me on that one
that little girl doesn't mean anything
she's nothing it's a whole lot of
nothing I don't need to worry about that
I gotta find this artifact this this
artifact uh key to another room I could
have just Bass Down the door I found it
304. how convenient okay so I'm guessing
it's easier up there sorry my voice is
already cracking just cause I haven't
been able to do anything other than
scream my ass off I wonder if that same
monster is gonna be crawling around the
other area I don't know
but it's not my intention to run into
her definitely not
no steamy okay I see a lot of pipes I
don't see a lot of steam
okay piece of [__] peace I swear to
nowhere
just let exactly nowhere
so I just there's only one other place
that it could be it's got to be up in
that other Alcove up there I just gotta
hope that she's not nearby or I don't
run into like a guillotine or something
or another monster that I don't know yet
oh yeah this way okay
I sure hope I don't run into the exit
that would be the worst since every time
I say something you seems to throw
something new at night
get me out of here
oh you're so nice to me you're so nice
to me there we go going down for some
train reason I think we're just
descending other levels of Hell to
torture ourselves with so that we don't
have to experience this life this lovely
life that I'm living oh
where am I going I go mentally insane
every time I play one of these videos is
this real or a nightmare
I don't know maybe this new key has the
answer hmm maybe or maybe not let's go
find out I think it's right across the
hall
isn't this one three or four right here
no 308
teddy bear
still there I should leave the Bear in
case they come back once again who's
coming back why are they
okay three or four is right yeah
what do you got for me show me
show me
hey how are you you look good
oh hi hi
okay
um I think the door is stuck
well all right then I see someone back
there oh you're creepy as hell what do
you want from me
huh
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take a good
look at you I'm gonna crank up the
brightness on this in post and see what
the she's moving
all right I'm out of here Jesus I can't
take I'm gonna get a good look at you
foreign
all right I'm on my way all right let me
just get downstairs just in case it's
like
oh
unless you got another one for me
God damn this game is good
it's good the game's good oh this game's
good oh this game's good
ask who you game
screw you hard
maybe this is the end of the demo I
don't know I don't know how much more
there is in this game oh that's the end
of it okay thank goodness oh my heart
can take a break that was amazing that
was absolutely awesome that was so scary
it was so damn terrifying okay so this
game is trying to get voted up on steam
green light it's worth it it's deserving
it's terrifying I think it's made by one
guy but either way it's fantastic one of
the best horror games I've played in a
long time so check it out for yourselves
thanks again everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
bye-bye
yourself
oh you're out already wait a minute
thank you